islamic parties aren't just in the
middle east anymore
belgium the country in europe is
scheduled to hold elections in just a
few months there's a rising star in the
political landscape there
it's called the islam party its state of
purpose is to implement
sharia and transform belgium into an
islamic state
members of the islam party won two races
in 2012 the party's hoping to expand its
success this round
katie hopkins writes for rebel media she
has traveled to the town of molenbeek
lots of jihadis there you may remember
it because it was the place the 2015
paris terrorists plotted their attack
she interviewed the town's mayor who
seemed to regard its ties to jihad
as a marginal issue at best watch were
you told that
salah abdullah was a suspected terrorist
in mullenberg were you given that list
were you given that information in
october 2016
15. yes well
we had a list but this list was
[Music]
known i i just
had a list of a few names names well i
would say more than
30 names but it was not the job of
the local police to follow those people
not my job she said katie hopkins joins
us tonight katie that's unbelievable did
are we misreading that because the
language barry did the mayor just say
it's not her job to keep track of
dangerous people in her community
absolutely she's the mayor of molenbeck
she's been there for about six years or
so now
she was given the name and the location
he ran a bar in the town
of the coordinator of the paris attacks
where 130 were killed
415 were maimed and when i said to her
you had that list you had his name
you did nothing she said it's not
my job it was not my job to do something
and of course this is part of the
problem in the jihadi capital of europe
where i've just spent three days
is that politicians turn a blind eye
because they are dependent on the voters
who are muslim and they want their
support so it's a demographic thing i
mean
at a certain point you become captive to
the people
who are changing your society that's
absolutely right you know what i've just
seen i've spent three days walking the
streets of marlon beck
it's known as a place that other
reporters won't go because it's
80 muslim there's a lot of sunnis there
a lot of salafists
a lot of shiites very hardcore kind of
religious individuals but you've got a
triumvirate the perfect storm
of a lot of unauthorized mosques
particularly controlled by
iran and money flowing in you've got one
type of population
80 percent moroccan heritage muslims
and then you've got politicians and
police who i'm told by
informers are taking backhanders who are
happy to turn a blind eye
and that's why you've got terror being
plotted
in belgium but that terror then of
course drives
two hours away to destroy people in
capital cities like london here
or indeed paris and bear in mind ramadan
is just around the corner
what do what do the rest of belgium
think of
think of this ordinary belgians are they
for them yeah it's so interesting
obviously there's a great deal of white
flight i walk through i think you have
images and stills there the marketplace
i was the only woman with my head
uncovered everybody there is in a burka
the islam party that are putting up 28
candidates in september
they want segregated transport
segregated living
and they want halal everywhere and
sharia and i can see it coming
so there's a massive white flight and
academics and
teachers and certain individuals tell me
their truths they will tell me
there are unauthorized mosques that the
teachers are giving up hope that people
want to move out
but they don't want to be seen to be
saying that because it goes against the
liberal narrative
but really these areas still exist
there's a massive mosque there
run by saudi it was given a 99-year free
lease on a massive building in belgium
as long as they could bring in
extremist imams to have access to these
migrants and then we wonder why
we end up living with the jihadis next
door
is this a permanent situation are these
people
residents citizens of belgium i mean is
it temporary
no it's not temporary at all they have
citizenship 95
000 people live in molonbeak about
85 percent of them are moroccan
heritage but they are french nationals
often belgian born
but what's so interesting and talking to
a teacher today who didn't want to be on
record
she was saying that her teaching
colleagues find that no matter what how
many generations in they are three
generations in now
they always have one foot still in
morocco and that's very much the point
that she made
those old islamic and muslim traditions
matter
more than any european heritage they may
have
amazing not the belgian most of us think
of katie hopkins thank you very much for
that
thank you tucker